All of us have no doubt felt the sting of guilt or shame, that uncomfortable sinking feeling when you know that you've done something wrong and the world is judging you for it, or maybe you're judging yourself. But although the words guilt and shame are sometimes used interchangeably, there are two distinct emotions that manifest differently and affect us in different ways. So what is the difference between shame and guilt? What role do these emotions play in our mental health? Are the useful tools of persuasion?
我们无疑都曾感受到内疚或羞耻的刺痛，那种当你意识到自己做错了事，而全世界都在评判你，或者你正在评判自己时，内心那种不舒服的下沉感。虽然“内疚”和“羞耻”这两个词有时可以互换使用，但它们是两种截然不同的情绪，表现方式不同，对我们的影响也不同。那么，羞耻和内疚之间有什么区别？这些情绪在我们的心理健康中扮演什么角色？它们是有效的说服工具吗？
Does trying to guilt or shame someone into changing their behavior usually work? How early in life do these emotions appear? When do children start to feel guilt and shame? Are some people more shame-prone or guilt-prone than others? And how does that affect their lives and choices? If guilt or shame is eating away at you, what can you do to address it? What if you feel guilty over something that isn't your fault or something that you can't change? What can you do then?
试图通过让某人感到内疚或羞耻来改变他们的行为通常有效吗？这些情绪在生命早期何时出现？儿童从什么时候开始感到内疚和羞耻？有些人是否比其他人更容易感到羞耻或内疚？这又如何影响他们的生活和选择？如果内疚或羞耻感正在蚕食你，你能做些什么来解决它？如果你因为不是你的错或你无法改变的事情而感到内疚怎么办？那时你能做什么？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. June Tangney, a distinguished university professor in the psychology department at George Mason University. She has spent her career studying how shame and guilt develop and how these emotions affect us. Dr. Tangney is an APA fellow and has authored or edited several books and published dozens of journal articles on shame, guilt, and other moral emotions. Her latest research focuses on shame and guilt in current and formerly incarcerated populations and on developing interventions to help the 11 million people who cycle through U.S. jails each year.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是乔治梅森大学心理学系杰出大学教授琼·坦格尼博士。她的职业生涯致力于研究羞耻和内疚是如何发展的，以及这些情绪如何影响我们。坦格尼博士是美国心理学会会士，曾撰写或编辑过几本书，并发表了数十篇关于羞耻、内疚和其他道德情绪的期刊文章。她最新的研究重点是当前和曾经被监禁人群中的羞耻和内疚感，以及开发干预措施，以帮助每年在美国监狱中循环往复的1100万人。
Dr. Tangney, thank you for joining me today. Thank you. It's a delight to be here. Let's start with the most basic question. What is the difference between shame and guilt? How do these emotions differ from each other? In a nutshell, when we feel shame, we feel bad about ourselves. We are fundamentally flawed because we did something. It reflects on who we are as a person.
坦格尼博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。让我们从最基本的问题开始。羞耻和内疚有什么区别？这些情绪彼此有何不同？简而言之，当我们感到羞耻时，我们对自己感觉很糟糕。我们认为自己从根本上有缺陷，因为我们做了某事。这反映了我们作为一个人的本质。
I'm a bad person for having done that. Guilt, in contrast, focuses on a behavior somewhat separate from the self. You can be a good person but do a bad thing. And so when people feel guilt, they feel typically bad about something that they've done, something specific or not done that they should have done. And are guilt and shame useful tools of persuasion? Can you guilt or shame someone into changing their behavior? You know, that's such an interesting question. And oddly, the interpersonal aspects of shame and game.
“我因为做了那件事而是一个坏人。”相比之下，内疚关注的是某种与自我相对独立的行为。你可以是一个好人，但做了一件坏事。因此，当人们感到内疚时，他们通常会对他们所做的事情，或者应该做而没做的事情感到难过。那么内疚和羞耻是有效的说服工具吗？你能通过让某人感到内疚或羞耻来改变他们的行为吗？你知道，这是一个非常有趣的问题。奇怪的是，羞耻和内疚的人际层面研究远少于你提到的其他问题，比如，嗯，感到适量的羞耻或适量的内疚是否健康？什么时候这对个人来说是有问题的？嗯，我认为下一代将更多地关注羞耻和内疚作为试图说服或控制他人的手段，而关于这方面的研究出奇地少。那么内疚和羞耻如何影响人们的心理健康？容易感到羞耻的人是否更容易患上某些心理健康疾病？
guilt have been studied much less than some of the other issues that you brought up, such as, um, is it healthy to feel, uh, a good amount of shame or a good amount of guilt? When is it problematic for the person? Um, I think the next generation is going to look much more at, um, shame and guilt as attempts to, uh, persuade or, uh, control other people. and there's surprisingly little research on that. So how do guilt and shame affect people's mental health? Are people who are prone to feeling shame more susceptible to some mental health disorders?
（接上文）
Yes, actually. Freud was wrong on one point. It turns out... Only one? Well, you know. He's quoted as saying guilt is the... the cause of neurosis. And actually, it seems to be more shame that people who are prone to feeling bad about themselves
是的，实际上。弗洛伊德在一点上错了。事实证明……只有一点？嗯，你知道的。他曾被引用说内疚是神经症的根源。实际上，似乎更多的是羞耻感，那些容易对自己感到糟糕的人
because they failed or transgressed, people who are prone to shame about the self are more susceptible to a range of different psychological and behavioral problems. that doesn't mean if you're shame prone that you're condemned to a life of misery. I didn't get into this just randomly. My mother's shame prone. I'm shame prone. One of my daughters is shame prone. The correlation is, you know, there are people who are shame prone who can manage it.
因为他们失败或犯了错，那些容易对自我感到羞耻的人更容易受到一系列不同的心理和行为问题的影响。但这并不意味着如果你容易感到羞耻，你就注定要过悲惨的生活。我不是随便进入这个领域的。我的母亲容易感到羞耻。我也容易感到羞耻。我的一个女儿也容易感到羞耻。这种相关性是，你知道，有些人虽然容易感到羞耻，但他们能够控制它。
And part of it is sort of resilience in managing it. And are there techniques? I mean, do you work with people and try to help them understand if you behave in a certain way, you can feel less shame, you can feel less guilt? Yeah, I think just actually telling people about educating them about the difference between shame and guilt, that typically when we feel shame, it's kind of out of proportion. You know, I may have hurt my friend's feelings and been thoughtless, but that doesn't mean I'm a terrible friend necessarily. I mean, and I think if you present people with the difference between two, there's often this aha sort of experience that people describe where, oh, you mean I don't have to feel really bad, the shame thing about me as a person?
其中一部分是管理它的韧性。那么有什么技巧吗？我的意思是，你是否与人们合作，帮助他们理解如果你以某种方式行事，你可以减少羞耻感，减少内疚感？是的，我认为仅仅是告诉人们，教育他们了解羞耻和内疚之间的区别，通常当我们感到羞耻时，它有点不成比例。你知道，我可能伤害了我朋友的感情，表现得不够体贴，但这并不一定意味着我是一个糟糕的朋友。我的意思是，我认为如果你向人们展示两者之间的区别，人们经常会描述一种“啊哈”式的体验，哦，你的意思是，我不必因为我这个人而感到非常糟糕，那种羞耻感？
I could feel guilt. And one of the big differences between shame and guilt has to do with what people are then motivated to do. and it turns out that, you know, we all fail and transgress at certain times, right? When people feel shame about their failures or transgressions, they're inclined to become defensive, to deny, to blame other people. So not really take responsibility and sometimes to get angry at other people for making them feel that way. But what they don't necessarily do is change their behavior.
我可以感到内疚。羞耻和内疚之间的一个重大区别与人们随后被激励去做的事情有关。事实证明，你知道，我们都会在某些时候失败和犯错，对吧？当人们对自己的失败或过错感到羞耻时，他们倾向于变得防御，去否认，去责怪他人。所以并没有真正承担责任，有时还会因为别人让他们感到那种羞耻而对他们生气。但他们不一定会改变自己的行为。
They don't own it because it's so painful to think I'm a horrible person and own that. When people feel guilt about something they've really done and just focus on, I feel bad that I did that, they're more inclined to, well, first of all, a behavior is easier to change than a self. you can make, people are pressed not to hide and escape and deny. When people feel guilt about a specific behavior, they're inclined to want to confess, apologize, make things right. So let me ask you a developmental question. At what age in life do guilt and shame begin to emerge? And do they emerge at the same time or different times?
他们不承认它，因为想到“我是一个可怕的人”并承认这一点太痛苦了。当人们对他们真正做过的事情感到内疚，并且只关注“我对自己做了那件事感到难过”时，他们更倾向于，嗯，首先，行为比自我更容易改变。你可以让人们不隐藏、不逃避、不否认。当人们对特定行为感到内疚时，他们倾向于想要坦白、道歉、弥补过失。那么让我问你一个发展方面的问题。内疚和羞耻在人生的什么年龄开始出现？它们是同时出现还是在不同时间出现？
You know, I would have to turn to my expert developmental psychologist. I've given this a lot of thought and dealt through the literature. And my understanding of the development of the self, really, and what's required to feel guilt about a behavior without feeling shame about the self is the ability to distinguish between what I do and who I am. I don't think that's something that very, very young children are able to do. I think that doesn't really emerge much before age seven or eight. It depends on the child, right? But clearly, children feel shame well before that. There's embarrassment, there's shame, you know, within the first two years of life.
你知道，我得求助于我的发展心理学家专家。我对此思考了很多，并查阅了文献。我对自我发展的理解，实际上，要在不感到自我羞耻的情况下对行为感到内疚，所需要的是区分“我所做的”和“我是谁”的能力。我不认为这是非常非常年幼的孩子能够做到的。我认为这在七八岁之前不会真正出现。这取决于孩子，对吧？但显然，孩子们在那之前很久就感到羞耻了。在生命的前两年内，就会有尴尬，有羞耻，你知道。
If guilt or shame is really interfering with your life, that it's not just an occasional reaction to a particular incident, but something that you feel frequently, what can you do to address that? And where might that be coming from? Well, people get stuck for a lot of different reasons. And I think that therapy can be very helpful. also confiding and working with a good friend who maybe is kinder to you than you are to yourself. But I think really recognizing the difference between I did a bad thing and therefore I'm a bad person
如果内疚或羞耻真的干扰了你的生活，它不仅仅是对特定事件的偶尔反应，而是你经常感受到的东西，你能做些什么来解决它？这可能来自哪里？嗯，人们因为很多不同的原因而陷入困境。我认为治疗非常有帮助。此外，向一位可能比你对自己更友善的好朋友倾诉并与他们合作。但我认为真正认识到“我做了一件坏事，因此我是一个坏人”之间的区别
and that's the take-home point as opposed to I did a bad thing. Now, what can I do about it? I was going to say, what about guilt over things that aren't your fault or are out of your control, like the kind of guilt that people feel when they survive a tragedy unscathed and a lot of other people are hurt? I've been giving that a lot of thought recently, I think partly because of the COVID pandemic and such. my measure, I have a measure of individual differences in proneness to shame and guilt, how much people are prone to guilt, how much people are prone to shame in general. And almost all of the items, the situations, refer to events where the person really did do something.
这是重点，而不是“我做了一件坏事，现在我能做些什么来弥补？”我本来想问，对于那些不是你的错或超出你控制范围的事情感到内疚怎么办，比如人们在灾难中毫发无损地幸存下来，而许多其他人受伤时感到的那种内疚？我最近一直在思考这个问题，我想部分是因为新冠疫情之类的原因。我的衡量标准，我有一个衡量个人在羞耻和内疚倾向上的差异的量表，人们在多大程度上容易感到内疚，在多大程度上容易感到羞耻。几乎所有的项目，即情境，都指的是个人确实做了某事。
You know, heard somebody's feelings, broke something, told a lie, you know, what have you. What I didn't include is feeling guilty about things that you didn't do that aren't your responsibility. And that's another huge swath of, you know, is it justified guilt? And I think, you know, the pandemic is a great example that, you know, for a long time, we just didn't know. I mean, you know, we may have passed along a terrible illness to a loved one without knowing that we had it or knowing how it was transmitted at some point. And yet we often feel guilty, I think, or many people do, for things that they couldn't have anticipated. They couldn't have known. And I think that's where really doing some careful rethinking, you know, with a good friend, a therapist, a counselor, a wise, loved one, to really look at it and say, well, could you have foreseen this?
你知道，伤害了某人的感情，弄坏了什么东西，撒了谎，你知道，诸如此类。我没有包括的是对你没做过、不是你责任的事情感到内疚。这是另一大块，你知道，这是合理的内疚吗？我认为，你知道，疫情就是一个很好的例子，你知道，很长一段时间里，我们只是不知道。我的意思是，你知道，我们可能在不知道自己患病或不知道它是如何传播的情况下，将一种可怕的疾病传染给了亲人。然而，我们经常感到内疚，我想，或者许多人会为他们无法预料的事情感到内疚。他们不可能知道。我认为这就是真正需要进行一些仔细反思的地方，你知道，与好朋友、治疗师、咨询师、睿智的亲人一起，真正审视它并说，好吧，你能预见到这一点吗？
did you really know? And I think along with that comes this idea that there's a zero-sum game, that that's how life is, that if I survived and somebody else didn't, I took something away from them. That's not how the world works, right? But we do have this sense that if I'm doing well, somebody else must be doing poorly, right? that there's only so much to go around.
你真的知道吗？我认为随之而来的是一种“零和博弈”的想法，即生活就是这样，如果我幸存下来而别人没有，我就从他们那里夺走了什么。世界不是这样运作的，对吧？但我们确实有这种感觉，如果我过得好，别人一定过得不好，对吧？即资源是有限的。
And that's generally not the case. The more we cooperate, for example, the better off we all are. So there are so-called negative emotions that have some positive or evolutionary reason for existence. Is there anything that's beneficial about guilt or shame? Do they help motivate people to do better, to become better people? I haven't seen much evidence of shame having that effect or being shame prone about day-to-day transgressions. I wonder, and I don't know yet, but I have a hunch, that there are pivotal points, maybe one or two or three in a person's life where they do something that really is over the top. against their beliefs and feel shame and maybe use that to sort of like, oh, boy, maybe I better
而这通常不是事实。例如，我们合作得越多，我们所有人的处境就越好。所以有所谓的负面情绪，它们有一些积极或进化的存在理由。内疚或羞耻有什么好处吗？它们是否有助于激励人们做得更好，成为更好的人？我没有看到太多证据表明羞耻有这种效果，或者对日常过错感到羞耻有这种效果。我想知道，虽然我还不知道，但我有一种预感，在一个人的一生中，可能有一两个或三个关键点，他们做了一些真正过分的事情，违背了他们的信仰，感到羞耻，并可能利用这一点来，哦，天哪，也许我最好
recalibrate and rethink things here. But certainly that's not something on a day-to-day basis that we need or should be doing. I did read a paper, and I wish I could remember the name of the authors, but it changed my whole thinking about shame. It's a 2022 article just recently came out. So my whole story has been, in a nutshell, guilt is good, shame is bad. Well, of course, it's not that simple. I'm delighted to see the next generation, you know, expanding and looking in a much more nuanced way at these emotions.
重新校准并重新思考这里的事情。但这肯定不是我们每天需要或应该做的事情。我确实读过一篇论文，我希望我能记住作者的名字，但它改变了我对羞耻的整个看法。这是一篇2022年刚刚发表的文章。所以我的整个故事简而言之就是：内疚是好的，羞耻是坏的。嗯，当然，事情没那么简单。我很高兴看到下一代，你知道，在扩展并以一种更细致的方式看待这些情绪。
But this paper, what it did show is that, you know, there's something about observing someone else being shame. that that is the key. I used to think that shame was around because it was useful back in pre-verbal days and, you know, for a variety of reasons, it was adaptive to shame people who were not able to keep up at the herd or whatever. But we're not there now. And so I used to think it was just a vestige of, you know,
但这篇论文确实表明，你知道，观察别人感到羞耻是有某种意义的。这就是关键。我过去认为羞耻的存在是因为它在语言前时代很有用，而且，你知道，出于各种原因，羞耻那些无法跟上群体的人是适应性的。但我们现在不在那个时代了。所以我过去认为它只是人类发展早期阶段的遗迹。
earlier times in human development. But now this paper suggests that if you and I are having an exchange, and let's say that you go water your lawn during a drought, and I call you out on it publicly, well, you're not likely to change that behavior, you're likely to get defensive and like what's your deal with telling me what to do and all like that. But other people watching us who see me shaming you are less likely themselves to go water their lawn. I mean, that wasn't the exact thing that they studied, but that was the basic idea is seeing others shamed is powerful. So it serves a purpose, yeah. Yes. And I thought that was just so interesting. Are guilt and shame universal, or are there people who,
但现在这篇论文表明，如果你和我正在进行交流，假设你在干旱期间去浇草坪，而我公开指责你，嗯，你不太可能改变那种行为，你很可能会变得防御，比如“你管我做什么干嘛”之类的。但看着我们的其他人，看到我羞辱你，他们自己就不太可能去浇草坪了。我的意思是，那不是他们研究的确切内容，但基本思想是看到别人被羞辱是很有力量的。所以它确实有目的，是的。是的。我觉得这太有趣了。内疚和羞耻是普遍存在的吗，还是有些人
never experience one or the other. That's a really interesting question. Michael Lewis, who is one of the pioneers in research on shame and guilt, he happened notion. He talked about some people are guilt blind. They just can't acknowledge or grapple with a human failure, a human sin, a human transgression. and just feel guilt, they automatically slide right into shame.
从来没有经历过其中一种或另一种。这是一个非常有趣的问题。迈克尔·刘易斯，羞耻和内疚研究的先驱之一，他碰巧有这个概念。他谈到有些人是“内疚盲”。他们只是无法承认或处理人类的失败、人类的罪恶、人类的过错，而只是感到内疚，他们会自动滑向羞耻。
And that that is, you know, really problematic in a lot of ways, right? In my work with people involved in the criminal justice system, I've worked mostly with people charged with felonies and, you know, really the full range. we've also assessed and studied psychopathy. And that's a relatively small percentage of people who are incarcerated only about 19%. Of those 19% who kind of reached criteria or threshold for being considered having psychopathy, they do feel shame. You know, it's easy to feel dist and humiliated and shamed,
这在很多方面确实是有问题的，对吧？在我与刑事司法系统中的人们的工作中，我主要与被指控犯有重罪的人一起工作，你知道，确实是全方位的。我们也评估和研究了精神病态。这在被监禁的人中比例相对较小，只有约19%。在那19%达到被认为患有精神病态的标准或阈值的人中，他们确实感到羞耻。你知道，感到沮丧、羞辱和羞耻很容易，
not about the things that you and I might feel shamed about, but shames that they got caught, you know, whatever. Gilt, not so much. That seems to be kind of missing some people. Yeah. Really being able to own a behavior and say, I'm saying, I did it, and I'm sorry. Are there other disorders that are associated with an inability to feel guilt?
不是因为你和我可能感到羞耻的事情，而是因为他们被抓住了，你知道，诸如此类。内疚，则没那么多。这似乎在某些人身上是缺失的。是的。真正能够承认一种行为并说，“我承认，我做了，我很抱歉。”还有其他与无法感到内疚相关的疾病吗？
I'm thinking, for example, borderline personality disorder where people tend not to feel like anything's their fault. Everybody else is aligned against them. So very, very complicated. I mean, shame-proneness is related to people with borderline personality disorder tend to be high in shame. But guilt? Not so much. I have to go back and look at the data. I mean, here's the thing is
我想到的是，例如，边缘性人格障碍，人们倾向于不觉得任何事情是他们的错。其他人都在针对他们。所以非常非常复杂。我的意思是，羞耻倾向与边缘性人格障碍患者有关，他们往往羞耻感很高。但内疚呢？没那么多。我得回去看看数据。我的意思是，事情是这样的：
if you feel both shame and guilt or if something is correlated with both shame and guilt, shame kind of takes over the whole picture. You know, what really matters is can you feel guilt about a behavior, own it and not get into this. what really is a very selfish, self-focused emotion. Me, me, me, me, me, me. I'm such a horrible person as opposed to I did a bad thing.
如果你同时感到羞耻和内疚，或者如果某事与羞耻和内疚都有关，羞耻会占据整个画面。你知道，真正重要的是你能否对一种行为感到内疚，承认它，而不是陷入这种实际上非常自私、以自我为中心的情绪中。“我，我，我，我，我，我。我是一个如此可怕的人”，而不是“我做了一件坏事”。
You know, I think that hurt your feelings. And it turns out that when people feel guilt about a specific behavior, they're more likely to feel empathy for the person that they hurt. if they feel shame about the same event, they're more likely, they're not so concerned about, gee, I hurt your feelings and I feel empathy for you. They have interpersonal concerns, but it's more like, what are you thinking of me? Are you thinking that I'm such a horrible person too? Now, I understand that there is a connection between being prone to shame and prone to a, anxiety. Can you talk about that, how that has arisen in people? Well, you know, it's not
你知道，我想那伤害了你的感情。事实证明，当人们对特定行为感到内疚时，他们更有可能对他们伤害的人产生同理心。如果他们对同一事件感到羞耻，他们更有可能，他们不太关心“哎呀，我伤害了你的感情，我为你感到同理心”。他们有人际方面的顾虑，但这更像是，“你在想我什么？你是否也认为我是一个如此可怕的人？”现在，我了解到容易感到羞耻和容易感到焦虑之间存在联系。你能谈谈这个吗，它是如何在人们身上产生的？嗯，你知道，不仅仅是
just anxiety. So, you know, we find that proneness to shame is associated with a whole range of internalizing and externalizing problems. So shame is associated with anxiety and depression in some people, right? It's associated. with aggression and anger and ineffective ways of managing anger for some people, for some people both. It's been linked to eating disorders. It's been linked to, so I think, you know, we don't know why some people are more susceptible to one kind of disorder as opposed to another.
焦虑。所以，你知道，我们发现羞耻倾向与一系列内化和外化问题有关。所以羞耻在某些人身上与焦虑和抑郁有关，对吧？它与某些人的攻击性、愤怒以及管理愤怒的无效方式有关，对某些人来说两者都有。它与饮食失调有关。它与……所以我想，你知道，我们不知道为什么有些人比其他人更容易患上某种疾病。
I think being shame prone doesn't necessarily put you on track to. experience certain kinds of symptoms. But it is an attack on the self that is painful and that, you know, serves to essentially disorganize the self and make it less effective. We're difficult to maintain, you know, a good sense of self-esteem and self-confidence. What about sex and age differences when it comes to shame? What have you found there?
我认为容易感到羞耻并不一定让你走上经历某些症状的轨道。但它确实是对自我的攻击，是痛苦的，而且，你知道，本质上起到了瓦解自我并使其效率降低的作用。很难保持，你知道，良好的自尊和自信。那么在羞耻方面，性别和年龄差异如何？你在那里发现了什么？
Ah, that's interesting. Females of all ages, whether you look at children or adolescents or college students or parents or grandparents or whatever, women, girls score high. than men or boys on both shame and guilt problems. But women score higher in pretty much all kinds of emotions except anger, which is about equivalent. Right. So there becomes the never-ending question of is it that women have more access to emotion, experience more emotions more intensely, or are we just better socialized to
啊，这很有趣。所有年龄段的女性，无论你是看儿童、青少年、大学生、父母还是祖父母，女性、女孩在羞耻和内疚问题上的得分都比男性或男孩高。但女性在几乎所有类型的情绪上得分都更高，除了愤怒，愤怒大约是相当的。对。所以这就引出了一个永无止境的问题：是女性有更多接触情绪的途径，更强烈地体验情绪，还是我们只是被更好地社会化以
recognize, acknowledge, and feel comfortable sharing that. You know, it's just hard to know. But what we have found is, although women may be more prone to shame than men, girls more than boys, the relationship of shame-proneness to aggression or depression or depression or what have you is about the same for men and women. So if you're a woman who experiences a lot more shame than the average woman, you're going to be just as susceptible as a man who experienced maybe a little less shame, but more than the average man is what it comes down. So how did you get interested in studying these topics? I understand that the time that you began to delve into it, that you're pretty much out there by yourself.
识别、承认并乐于分享这些情绪？你知道，这很难说。但我们发现的是，虽然女性可能比男性更容易感到羞耻，女孩比男孩更容易，但羞耻倾向与攻击性或抑郁等之间的关系对于男性和女性来说大致相同。所以，如果你是一个比普通女性经历更多羞耻感的女性，你将和经历可能少一点羞耻感但比普通男性多的男性一样容易受到影响，这就是结论。那么你是怎么对研究这些话题感兴趣的？我了解到你开始深入研究的时候，你几乎是孤军奋战。
Well, it was. I was born not to do this. It was a well-intentioned senior mentors and like that. Although I have to say, Cy Feshbach, my graduate advisor, we did some work on television and children. And after I graduated, I said, Cy, you know, I'm really not that interested in this. And I'm sure he had hoped that I would continue in that area. I said, you know, I'm interested in the shame and guilt stuff.
嗯，确实是。我生来就不是为了做这个的。这是出于好意的资深导师之类的。虽然我必须说，赛·费什巴赫，我的研究生导师，我们做了一些关于电视和儿童的工作。毕业后，我说，“赛，你知道，我对这个真的不太感兴趣。”我敢肯定他希望我能继续那个领域。我说，“你知道，我对羞耻和内疚的东西很感兴趣。”
I know it's kind of flaky and everybody's telling me it's flaky, but, and he's like, go for it. Just go for it. And I am so grateful for that. I was really very much influenced by Helen Block Lewis, who wrote a book in 1971 that laid out this distinction between shame and guilt that seems to be well supported now. And I was also very, very much influenced by Norma Feshbach, who made a career out of articulating theoretically what empathy is and then coming up with a measure. And for me, you know, I saw her make a wonderful career that way and thought, well, shame and guilt. Now there's an interesting one. I did mention that I was raised Catholic,
“我知道这有点不靠谱，每个人都告诉我这不靠谱，但是……”他说，“去吧。尽管去吧。”我对此非常感激。我真的深受海伦·布洛克·刘易斯的影响，她在1971年写了一本书，阐述了羞耻和内疚之间的这种区别，现在看来得到了很好的支持。我也深受诺玛·费什巴赫的影响，她通过在理论上阐明什么是同理心，然后提出一种衡量标准，成就了一番事业。对我来说，你知道，我看到她以那种方式成就了美好的事业，心想，嗯，羞耻和内疚。那是一个有趣的话题。我确实提到我是天主教徒长大的，
so it kind of made a joke about that. But I want to, so everybody always asked me, you haven't yet about religion. That was my next question. So I just assumed because I was Catholic, that's how I got into this. And, you know, I can tell you a little bit about what my thoughts were on this back when I was six.
所以开了一个关于那个的玩笑。但我想要，所以每个人总是问我，你还没提到宗教。那是我的下一个问题。所以我只是假设因为我是天主教徒，所以我才进入这个领域。而且，你知道，我可以告诉你一点我六岁时对此的想法。
But it turns out when you actually look at, like shame-proneness and guilt-proneness for people who are Jewish versus Catholic versus some other kind of Christian versus Hindu versus atheists versus agnastics. There's just almost no difference at all. But it's amazing. It's like something that should be there that's not. And we've looked at current religious affiliation. and we've also looked at religious affiliation as, you know, a child,
但事实证明，当你真正观察犹太教徒、天主教徒、其他类型的基督徒、印度教徒、无神论者或不可知论者在羞耻倾向和内疚倾向上的差异时，几乎没有任何区别。但这很神奇。就像有些东西应该在那里，但却不在。我们观察了当前的宗教信仰，我们也观察了作为儿童时的宗教信仰，
because sometimes people change their religions and religious beliefs in adulthood. Doesn't matter. Nobody's got a corner on shame or guilt, and we're all susceptible, you know, for better or worse. And I think the big thing is to figure out ways to make the most of these negative emotions and be able to resolve them in constructive ways and then move on. Well, I will confess that I too was raised Roman Catholic, and I have always had the sense that shame and guilt were tools to get you to tow the religious line.
因为有时人们在成年后会改变他们的宗教和宗教信仰。没关系。没有人垄断了羞耻或内疚，我们都容易受到影响，你知道，无论好坏。我认为最重要的是找到方法来充分利用这些负面情绪，并能够以建设性的方式解决它们，然后继续前进。好吧，我承认我也曾是罗马天主教徒，我一直觉得羞耻和内疚是让你遵守宗教准则的工具。
I mean, it was a way of controlling people. If you felt shame or guilt around the things that the church told you, you should feel shameful and guilty about. You would be a better member of the church. I mean, the fact that you had to go to confession, I mean, when I was a kid, they wanted to confess your sins every Saturday night. It was dreadful.
我的意思是，这是一种控制人的方式。如果你对教会告诉你应该感到羞耻和内疚的事情感到羞耻或内疚，你就会成为教会更好的成员。我的意思是，你必须去忏悔的事实，我的意思是，当我还是个孩子的时候，他们想让你每个星期六晚上都忏悔你的罪。那太可怕了。
Well, yeah. And God forbid you should forget one because that's not going to be forgiven. God knows. I'm sure. Right. It's an interesting take on that. The message I got.
嗯，是的。上帝保佑你不要忘记一个，因为那不会被原谅。上帝知道。我肯定。对。这是一个有趣的看法。我得到的信息。
actually was, and this really disturbed me a lot, was, I grew up in Buffalo. I don't know if the Roman Catholic churches are more graphic than other places, but as a child, you know, I was surrounded by these, you know, the stations of the cross that were very, very gory for a child. Yes. And the emphasis was on how much suffering Jesus did for us worthless, people and of course I'm going to sin right I'm not a I knew by age four I wasn't going to be a saint the message I got was the better the person you are the worse you should feel well that's really troubling I should feel really bad and that'll make me a good person where does that get us
实际上是，这真的让我很困扰，是，我在布法罗长大。我不知道罗马天主教堂是否比其他地方更生动，但作为一个孩子，你知道，我被这些，你知道，非常非常血腥的苦路站所包围，对一个孩子来说。是的。重点在于耶稣为我们这些毫无价值的人承受了多少痛苦，当然我会犯罪，我知道，我四岁时就知道我不会成为圣人。我得到的信息是，你越好，你应该感觉越糟。嗯，这真的很令人不安。我应该感觉非常糟糕，那会让我成为一个好人。这把我们带向了哪里？
so that was my conundrum and so it was it was it was it was It would seem to me that at least it's being better understood that that's not necessarily the best motivator in the world. I mean, like my sense today is that, for example, when you go to your physician, you're, you know, your primary care physician, that you're not shamed into, oh, you weigh too much. You know, if you don't deal with your weight, you're going to die. Instead, they look at your weight and then they talk up generally about how you're doing. You know, are you getting that sense as well that there is an understanding that shaming people into changing their
所以那是我的难题，所以它，它，它，它。在我看来，至少人们正在更好地理解那不一定是世界上最好的激励因素。我的意思是，比如我今天的感受是，例如，当你去看医生时，你的初级保健医生，你不会因为“哦，你太重了”而感到羞耻。你知道，如果你不处理你的体重，你就会死。相反，他们看你的体重，然后谈论你整体做得如何。你知道，你也有这种感觉吗，即人们有一种理解，即羞辱人们去改变他们的
behavior is not effective? Yes, and I think one place where that has been just a tremendous shift is in treatment of substance abuse disorders. So it used to be the interventions that were truly shaming events where everybody gets together and dumps on the person with the substance abuse problem. And, you know, nowadays, well, you know, we have just a much more. we're kind and gentle way of approaching that that does not involve shame, but support and love. What's the relationship between shame and embarrassment?
行为是无效的？是的，我认为有一个领域发生了巨大的转变，那就是药物滥用障碍的治疗。所以过去，干预措施确实是羞辱性的事件，每个人聚在一起，把药物滥用问题的人贬低一通。而且，你知道，如今，嗯，你知道，我们有一种更友善、更温和的方法，不涉及羞耻，而是支持和爱。羞耻和尴尬之间的关系是什么？
Oh, yes. That's so interesting. I think many people think of embarrassment is kind of a a less intense, milder version of shame, it turns out that embarrassment and shame are really quite different. First of all, people can feel ashamed when they're alone. They most often feel shamed in social situations or about social events, but people almost never feel embarrassed when they're by themselves. I mean, you can do whatever you want in your living room, as long as your blinds are drawn, right?
哦，是的。这太有趣了。我认为许多人认为尴尬是一种强度较低、较温和的羞耻版本，事实证明尴尬和羞耻确实非常不同。首先，人们在独处时会感到羞耻。他们最常在社交场合或关于社交事件时感到羞耻，但人们几乎从不在独处时感到尴尬。我的意思是，只要拉上窗帘，你可以在客厅里做任何你想做的事，对吧？
But, and then when people feel embarrassed, there's kind of something a little funny and amusing about it, you know? The embarrassment, look, I wish I know we're doing a podcast, but it looks a little like shame, like you're kind of looking down, but you're sort of looking up and there's a little smile and, you know, it happened, and there's nothing funny about shame at all. It is not funny. It hurts.
但是，当人们感到尴尬时，它有点滑稽和有趣，你知道？尴尬，看，我希望我知道我们在做播客，但它看起来有点像羞耻，就像你有点向下看，但你有点向上看，有一个小微笑，你知道，它发生了，而羞耻中没有任何有趣的东西。它一点也不有趣。它很痛。
And if you can bring some levity and some humor to it in a way that's supportive, that's a wonderful thing to do for a partner or a loved one. Now, I know that a lot of the work you're doing now involves interventions to help people in the criminal justice system. How can our knowledge and understanding of shame and guilt be leveraged? to help people who are in that system? You know, I'm not sure that that is the most important direction at this point. You know, I mean, that's originally how I got involved in doing research with this population was thinking that we could leverage shame and guilt and such. I you know the biggest predictor of
如果你能以一种支持性的方式给它带来一些轻松和幽默，那对伴侣或爱人来说是一件美妙的事情。现在，我知道你现在所做的很多工作涉及帮助刑事司法系统中的人们的干预措施。我们对羞耻和内疚的知识和理解如何被利用？来帮助系统中的人们？你知道，我不确定那是目前最重要的方向。你知道，我的意思是，那最初是我参与研究这个人群的方式，当时认为我们可以利用羞耻和内疚之类的东西。我，你知道，最大的预测因素
changing one's behavior and not recidivating of not being reincarcerated is not misusing substances that's you know one really big thing the other biggest predictor is self-control and so that that does pose some interesting angles of how to help people increase a sense of self-control in areas that are important to them,
改变一个人的行为而不重犯，不被重新监禁，不是滥用物质，那是，你知道，一件非常大的事情。另一个最大的预测因素是自我控制，所以这确实提出了一些有趣的角度，关于如何帮助人们在对他们重要的领域增加自我控制感，
and especially around substance abuse. Substance abuse is a funny area because nobody really owns it. Like clinical psychology is like, this isn't our thing. We don't do this. And yeah, social workers are kind of like, well, that's not really our thing. And it just sort of, I don't know, nobody really quite has owned it. Perhaps because it's so difficult. Well, there's a lot of hope.
特别是在药物滥用方面。药物滥用是一个有趣的领域，因为没有人真正拥有它。临床心理学就像，“这不是我们的事。我们不做这个。”是的，社会工作者有点像，“嗯，那真的不是我们的事。”它只是，我不知道，没有人真正拥有它。也许是因为它太难了。嗯，有很多希望。
And many different humane approaches, much more so than interventions. You know, the shamed fests. And some work for others and some work for some, some for others. So just to wrap up, I like to ask. researchers, what else they're working on? What's your next big project? I'm not really quite sure. I'm at crossroads right now. I don't, it's difficult right now with COVID still, you know, in the background to do the kind of research we were doing in the jails and prisons. You know, having people from outside coming in, I mean, it's just
以及许多不同的人道方法，比干预措施多得多。你知道，羞耻盛宴。有些人有效，有些人无效，有些人有效，有些人无效。所以最后，我想问。研究人员，他们还在研究什么？你的下一个大项目是什么？我不太确定。我现在正处于十字路口。我不知道，现在新冠疫情还在背景中，很难做我们在监狱里做的那种研究。你知道，让外面的人进来，我的意思是，它只是
it's made it, you know, a difficult situation, even more difficult. Right now I'm really focused on seeing the last of my graduate students get where they want to go. And then thinking about next steps, I think maybe stepping back and looking at clinical psychology more broadly what it offered. when it's helpful and when it's not. And what non-specialists can expect and what's okay and what's not okay. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been a pleasure talking with you.
让它，你知道，一个困难的情况，变得更加困难。现在我真的专注于看着我的最后一个研究生去他们想去的地方。然后考虑下一步，我想也许退后一步，更广泛地看看临床心理学提供了什么。什么时候有帮助，什么时候没有。非专业人士可以期待什么，什么可以，什么不可以。好吧，我要感谢你今天加入我。和你谈话很愉快。
Thank you. I have really enjoyed it. And I want to thank APA for all their support of science and the marriage of clinical work in science. We will keep that up. Thanks. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review.
谢谢。我真的很享受。我也要感谢美国心理学会对科学以及临床工作与科学结合的所有支持。我们会保持下去。谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取最喜爱播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyne. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，你可以通过 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 给我们发电子邮件。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。